[Musica]
parliamo di lavoro
alzi la mano chi di voi ha cambiato
lavoro nel corso dell'ultimo anno
vedo vedo un po di vedo un po di mani
alzate
sappiate che non siete soli perché come
voi
550 mila persone hanno lasciato
volontariamente il loro lavoro solo nel
corso dell'ultimo trimestre del 2021 con
numeri record e mai rilevati prima è
quel fenomeno che prende il nome di
grandi dimissioni forse ne avete sentito
parlare
studi e ricerche stanno cercando di
definire l'identikit di queste persone
che decidono di lasciare il loro lavoro
comprenderne e le cause scoprendo che si
tratta in realtà di un fenomeno
piuttosto trasversale in termini di età
genere e professioni
c'è chi decide di lasciare il proprio
lavoro per cercare un lavoro un po più
stimolante chi lascia ambienti di lavoro
che potremmo definire tossici dove ci
sono cattive relazioni di lavoro
chi cerca lavoro un po meno stressanti
sicuramente in un qualche modo ci
ritorna alla mente quell acronimo jolo
you only live mans e quindi avere
maggiore consapevolezza del fatto che le
nostre scelte di vita sono fortemente
intersecate con le nostre scelte
lavorative
se non sappiamo ancora molte cose sulle
grandi dimensioni quello che sappiamo
per certo è che una delle tante
conseguenze del copit la pandemia ha
cambiato il nostro concetto di ufficio
il nostro nostro concetto di tempo di
lavoro il nostro concetto di come
lavoriamo con quali strumenti andiamo a
lavorare
ma soprattutto ha cambiato il
significato e l'importanza che
assegniamo al lavoro nella nostra vita
in altre parole come interpretiamo la
nostra carriera lavorativa
se come hanno fatto alcuni speaker che
mi hanno preceduto
vi chiedessi di chiudere per un attimo
gli occhi e pensare un'immagine la prima
che vi viene in mente quando sentite
l'espressione fare carriera
sono sicuro che molti di voi
penserebbero a un'immagine simile a
questa una scala
carriera deriva dal provenzale e
indicava quella parte della strada che
era dedicata alle corse dove i car i
carri erano trainati dai cavalli quindi
un percorso fisso è predeterminato e
pensate che noi usiamo la stessa
identica parola per parlare della nostra
vita lavorativa quindi un percorso che
ha un unico punto di arrivo che
chiamiamo successo che prevede una sola
direzione di mobilità verticale
e che non prevede deviazioni perché ogni
gradino segue ordinatamente quello
precedente
questa idea di carriera deriva in realtà
da modelli di gestione delle aziende del
personale che sono vecchi di oltre un
secolo ma ha una forza evocativa ancora
molto importante e nonostante questo
sono sicura che rappresenti solamente
una piccola minoranza dei percorsi
professionali vostri che vivete
quotidianamente ma allora di che
mobilità lavorativa ha senso parlare
oggi nel 2022 in un periodo post
pandemico in un periodo di
trasformazione digitali di un'attenzione
maggiore alle dimensioni etiche e di
sostenibilità del lavoro
cominciamo dalla fine dal punto di
arrivo il successo
per comprendere cosa significhi per
ciascuno di noi il successo vi chiederei
di provare a terminare questa frase
sarò soddisfatto o soddisfatta della mia
carriera quando
magari non l'ho fatta adesso potete
pensarci ma vi chiedo di portare questa
frase con voi
con un gruppo internazionale di
ricercatori
abbiamo chiesto di concludere questa
frase a oltre 18mila persone in 30 paesi
scoprendo tante differenze collegate
alla cultura ai diversi livelli di
sviluppo economico e sociale dei paesi
ma anche tantissimi larita dalla nostra
ricerca sono immersi innanzitutto i
significati più tradizionali di successo
quindi ottenere tante promozioni avere
un buono stipendio per altre persone
però avere successo a che fare con il
proprio sviluppo professionale quindi
avere un lavoro nel quale si impara
continuamente o nel quale si possono
realizzare progetti ad esempio anche una
propria impresa per altre persone avrei
successo invece a che fare con il
proprio ruolo sociale
quindi trovare un equilibrio ad esempio
tra le proprie identità multiple perché
io sono una lavoratrice ma sono anche
una figlia una sorella un'amica e quindi
ci sono tutte queste mie identità che
devono essere presenti sul luogo di
lavoro
per altri ancora avere successo
significa avere buone relazioni sul
lavoro essere apprezzati dai propri
responsabili e dai propri colleghi per
altri ancora avere successo significa
avere un lavoro attraverso il quale si
può fare qualcosa per gli altri e magari
provare a cambiare la società nella sua
interezza
abbiamo quindi sfatato il primo mito
relativo alla carriera intesa come una
scala il punto di arrivo non è unico ma
è diverso per ciascuno di noi e cambia
nel corso del tempo per questo motivo è
importante portare con sé questa frase e
magari utilizzarla un po come una
bussola
professionale nel momento in cui
decidiamo di dare una svolta alla nostra
carriera perché i nostri cambiamenti non
siano tanto dettati da lasciare qualcosa
che non ci piace ma piuttosto dall
andare verso qualcosa che desideriamo
altrimenti sarebbe un po come guidare
un'automobile guardando nello
specchietto retrovisore anziché davanti
a voi
la seconda caratteristica
della scala e che prevede una sola
dimensione di crescita cioè verticale
raramente però le nostre carriere sono
unidirezionali nel senso che molti di
voi avranno fatto passaggi orizzontali
all'interno della stessa azienda avranno
cambiato azienda e area avranno magari
ha avuto dei lavori in cui crescevano in
termini di responsabilità rimanendo
nella stessa posizione oppure saranno
usciti da un'azienda per poi rientrarvi
successivamente in un'altra posizione
ancora oltre a non essere unidirezionale
la nostra carriera non è neanche
unidimensionale cioè non è fatta
solamente di esperienze lavorative
perché tutto quello che noi facciamo
lavorativo e no va a costruire
quell'insieme di conoscenze
relazioni e motivazioni che definiscono
il nostro percorso professionale
quando alla radio o in internet
ascoltiamo un webinar sulla leadership
oppure
organizziamo la vacanza per il nostro
figlio
stiamo acquisendo conoscenze di
leadership appunto e sviluppando
competenze di pianificazione che
potrebbero esserci utili sul lavoro
quando partecipiamo a un tè dx
quando facciamo un viaggio con delle
persone
sviluppiamo delle relazioni che potranno
esserci utili per cambiare il nostro
lavoro in tutte le occasioni che vi ho
appena elencato
stiamo facendo che cosa stiamo prendendo
consapevolezza delle nostre competenze
delle nostre aspettative e quindi
implicitamente ci poniamo nuovamente la
domanda sul nostro obiettivo
professionale
abbiamo quindi sfatato il secondo mito
relativo alla scala fare carriere non
significa solo andare verso l'alto ma
andare verso il nostro obiettivo
con tutte le pause le interruzioni i
cambi di direzione che sono tipici di un
percorso nel quale non controlliamo
tutto e non possiamo prevedere è tutto
se questo è vero capite che più che la
scala che vi ho mostrato prima la nostra
carriera assomiglierà una scala più come
questa qui
la terza caratteristica della scala è la
sequenza di gradini per salire sul
gradino successivo devi essere passato
sui gradini precedenti
riportato al mondo del lavoro questo
significa che le nostre possibilità
future dipendono dalle nostre
possibilità ai nostri lavori presenti e
passati è il modello dello specialismo
della crescita verticale all'interno di
una certa area di professionalità nella
quale noi siamo esperti
è quello che accade quando un giovane si
laurea in economia va a lavorare magari
nell'area commerciale di un'azienda
farmaceutica dopo un po di anni decide
di cambiare lavoro e cosa cercherà
probabilmente cercherà un lavoro nello
stesso settore nella stessa area per
fare che cosa per sfruttare le
competenze che ha accumulato le
esperienze che ha sviluppato nella prima
esperienza di lavoro e così via nel
corso del tempo tanto che la scala
diventa una gabbia professionale sempre
più stretta
potremmo chiederci se questo modello
sarà quello vincente anche in futuro
secondo l'ultimo report del world
economic forum
proprio sul futuro del lavoro il 40 per
cento delle competenze che oggi
consideriamo fondamentali sul nostro
lavoro saranno obsolete nel 2025 tre
anni
se questo è vero il suggerimento è
quello di sviluppare il nostro percorso
di carriera non tanto come una i ma
piuttosto come una t dove la parte
verticale della ii la nostra area di
specializzazione mentre la parte
orizzontale della t sono un insieme di
competenze trasversali di comunicazione
di gestione di progetti che ad esempio
potrebbero esserci utili per parlare con
altre persone in azienda o per muoverci
in altre aree di specializzazione in
futuro
e così abbiamo sfatato anche il terzo
mito relativo alla scala fare carriera
non è un percorso unico in cui il
passato predice il futuro ma piuttosto è
un insieme di tanti brevi cicli di
apprendimento in cui in ogni esperienza
professionale impariamo qualcosa di
nuovo e questo aumenta le nostre
competenze e ci apre nuove possibilità
in futuro
parlare di lavoro e carriera oggi
significa quindi confrontarsi con una
molteplicità di percorsi che non possono
essere ridotti a delle i delitti oppure
all'immagine di una scala potremmo
piuttosto parlare di un alfabeto
professionale in cui ciascuno di noi può
riconoscersi in una lettera o potrebbe
costruire la propria lettera che
rappresenta il percorso che vuole
seguire per raggiungere il proprio
obiettivo di carriera
magari con questo alfabeto professionale
può trovare la propria personale
risposta alla domanda
sarò soddisfatto soddisfatta della mia
carriera quando
grazie
[Applauso]